[Música]
pese a los intentos de occidente por la
vía diplomática para rebajar las
tensiones entre rusia y ucrania la
amenaza de una posible invasión desde
moscú es cada vez más latente el kremlin
mantiene en su discurso que no piensa
iniciar un conflicto bélico sin embargo
en la última jornada hubo ensayos
militares desde rostov y se envió más
armamento a belarús mientras que miles
de soldados siguen apostados cerca de
territorio ucraniano para rebajar la
atención de vladimir putin exige que
ucraniano entre a la otan y que salgan
de la alianza los países que están en su
zona de influencia y que se unieron
después del 97 la organización del
tratado del atlántico norte se niega a
cumplir esas demandas en negociaciones
que por el momento ha liderado a eeuu
porque la expansión de la otan es motivo
de preocupación para rusia
vamos al análisis con nuestro primer
invitado del día del doctor 8 jaén
kleinschmidt politólogo e investigador
de la universidad católica de state
ingolstadt señor klein mit buenos días
es bienvenido y occidente acusa a rusia
de planear una invasión a ucrania y de
elevar las tensiones en la zona con la
movilización de tropas sin embargo fue
rusia el país iniciador de este
conflicto o hay una suerte de
provocaciones dados los acercamientos
entre ucrania y la otan
bueno en realidad es rusia que inició
esta situación problemática con el
despliegue realmente enorme armas y
posiblemente más de la mitad de su
ejército de tierra en la frontera con
ucrania y también tiene ahora tropas
pasadas en belorrusia así que a un
inicio rusia y está haciendo también
demandas que en occidente se están
observando como como se están viendo
como absurdas como por ejemplo están
exigiendo de eeuu prometer que ucraniano
se va a apuntar a la otan cuando en
realidad
eeuu no puede dar promesas para 30 otros
países así que a la la atmósfera general
en la votan entre los expertos de
seguridad etcétera es una de
incertidumbre y extrema preocupación
hay básicamente dos
tendencias de pensamiento unos dicen que
si esto es estos son las preparaciones
para una invasión en ucrania para volver
cráneo a un imperio
soviético esencialmente y hay otra
tendencia que dice no eso es
esencialmente un gran espectáculo para
para fortalecer las diferencias con
respecto a rusia entre países de
occidente y así para generar en el para
general para romper esencialmente la
unidad de occidente frente a las
sanciones comerciales a rusia bueno y es
algo que veremos con el avance de los
días de esta semana podría incluso ser
clave profesor le quiero preguntar qué
fue lo que disparó el gatillo para que
rusia reaccionará con tanta agresividad
en estas últimas de semanas podría tener
algo que ver la atención entre belarús y
los países de la unión europea
en realidad las tensiones entre
belorrusia y la unión europea son
buenas para rusia en términos de su
política exterior porque quitan la
opción occidental a belorussia que se ve
que anteriormente trató de mantener una
cierta independencia frente a rusia eso
ya no existe así que no creo que eso sea
el factor creo que hay algunos factores
que que son importantes son aun la
credibilidad reducida de eeuu después de
su retiro de afganistán puede ser puede
ser también la alta dependencia
de algunos países de occidente sobre
todo de alemania el gas natural de rusia
y la escasez de gas natural en los
mercados globales y la situación de
invierno obviamente
también puede ser que aún es la
situación política interna de rusia con
una popularidad reducida del gobierno de
putin como una economía estancada en
realidad desde ya casi 7 años y aún
puede ser que es simplemente la
confluencia de esos factores que genera
aún que genera ese comportamiento bueno
profesores y otro tema de que se ha
calentado en las últimas horas es la
posibilidad de sanciones directas contra
vladimir putin que ya lo anuncio joe
biden y se sumó el reino unido-
posiblemente para tomar esta acción sin
embargo esta no es la primera vez que
llegan sanciones a rusia y ha sabido
rebatir los bastante bien realmente van
a causar una afectación importante a la
economía rusa
bueno las sanciones personales contra
putin no van a tener ningún efecto pues
un efecto simbólico tal vez pero si
tiene a su disposición es esencialmente
la entera economía rusa puede mandar que
el estado le construya palacios como
hemos visto en publicaciones recientes y
eso no es
eso no es lo relevante lo que sí puede
ser relevante sería por ejemplo la
desconexión de rusia de la red swift que
que conecta a los bancos del mundo para
transacciones electrónicas eso podría
dificultar enormemente
su exportación por ejemplo de petróleo
de gas natural etcétera
además
la situación está generando incomodidad
también en países neutrales como suecia
o finlandia donde se está iniciando una
discusión sobre posiblemente juntarse o
acercarse a la otan y podría tener
entonces
consecuencias directamente o fuerzas a
las que el kremlin no oficialmente está
buscando y otro de los actores en este
conflicto el papel de europa en la
crisis hasta el momento se ha limitado a
seguir las directrices desde washington
qué papel podría jugar el bloque en este
conflicto más hoy que se ven las
conversaciones o se esperan las
conversaciones de normandía
existe están
empieces se están empezando a esas
conversaciones de nuevo en círculos de
expertos hay cierto que sí mismo al
respeto las posiciones en realidad son
demasiado diferentes y las demandas de
las últimas semanas desde moscú han sido
tan
irracionales que en realidad es difícil
ver cómo se podrían generar discusiones
productos producentes aún
el papel de europa en general
no no ha jugado ningún papel como
institución porque europa no dispone de
capacidades militares en realidad se han
hecho una cosa
han fortalecido el papel de la otan en
la seguridad europeo otra vez y
económicamente son solo algunos países
de la unión europea que tienen realmente
una interacción relevante con rusia
sobre todo alemania y alemania ha
seguido un curso que algunos analistas
llaman neutralista es visto como más y
más problemático por los países vecinos
de rusia que son parte de la otan o de
la unión europea es visto también como
problemático
entre expertos
estadounidenses de seguridad por
esencialmente habilitar ese
comportamiento
confrontativo de moscú en la crisis